alright ladies and gentlemen it's time
to do a spoiler talk for Star Wars
Episode nine the rise of Skywalker but
before we begin spoiling undoubtedly the
best Star Wars movie ever everyone can
agree on that and everyone can also
agree that our best sponsorship
shoutouts have been for this month
sponsored Hasse intercom hosting Stinger
at long last we Jedi
huh he said last so like the last ship
we have our very own homepage the real
rejects dot-com it's still a work in
progress and Jon will continue tweaking
it in the new year right Jon
am I the only one working but luckily
hosting derp makes registering your
domain and building your first web site
a breeze like the way this trilogy is
looking to turn your Jedi power battles
into Let's Plays take advantage of
hosting or virtual private servers
finally ready to publish that thirteen
part essay on your intense love for Star
Wars Episode nine the rise the best
Skywalker movie hosting er is integrated
with WordPress to help you get that blog
up and running they can even help you
open a Web Store so you can finally get
your life size crochet reloj dolls to
the people what about Finn Oh dolls
Finn oh yeah like why she's right better
jokes for me next time John I'm sorry
know what she's do your thing were you
point to the posting or offers a variety
of fast and secure options as well as 24
hour customer service and when you visit
hosting or comm slash the real rejects
and enter our special promo code the
real rejects you can save a full ninety
one percent on one of hosting our annual
hosting plans that's almost a hundred
percent which is the rotten tomato score
for the rise of Skiles so what you
waitin for people visit hosting or comm
slash the real rejects today
all right on to the spoiler talk you
guys have been warned so I just want to
tease some things that we are going to
discuss there's gonna be more than this
starting off with like the heavy amount
of course corrections Emperor Palpatine
returning how they handled that
ultimately kylo ren's character arc
transition Princess Leia
Rey's parents ei they're discovered Rey
being a Palpatine Rey killing Palpatine
the whole MarySue but I usually call it
god mode abilities of Rey and how that's
all continuously handled just as the
trilogy Rey taking the Skywalker name
reloj things that were wasted dropped or
just dumb look some minor examples
general Hux Knights of Ren the four
solves everything apparently sort of
surprising appearances some Easter eggs
and such we're not gonna go over all
them there's so much movie here we're
not gonna break this whole thing down
but if some Easter eggs come up they
come up we're gonna dive into this have
a little bit of freeform but these are
gonna be like primarily the topics we'll
be focusing on the experience has been
interesting the time of filming this we
shot our non-spoiler review yesterday
immediately leaving the theater as I was
editing the review I mean John was with
me for most of the day at night I kept
telling him like this is coming across
like I love this movie when I really
don't like kept doing those like random
inserts in there there's a reason I
haven't read every comment because with
a movie that's getting this much
backlash and it was expected that it
would it's hard to fall under the gray
area of things I noticed yeah and I mean
I don't know I personally just as a you
know being here I didn't think it
sounded too positive
I don't not retracting anything I said
like I what I thought was positive and
good about the movie I do think that so
if you wanna know what's like good about
the bet I personally liked it's all
night someone asked me like what would I
give a percentage of this and I said 60%
and funny enough there's like fifty six
percent and the thing is though at the
time of filming it I was really honing
in more on like that's that positive 60
I felt but then as the day kept going
and like I was talking with my
girlfriend I was sorry when they Angie
talked with a guy for an arrant talked
with you I'm just yeah you know and
percolate a lot of the problems and I
wanted to make sure we shot our spoiler
talk before anyone put theirs out
because I didn't want anyone's opinions
influencing mine cuz I want to make sure
I'm coming from a sincere place there's
a lot of issues I had with this movie
walking out of it I think because I
binge the movie because I just wanted to
get all the information I wasn't even
really judging the film's per se I was
like I just wanna was what the
information and truth be told there's a
little bit of a bias I developed through
binging the film's I just like being in
the universe even if I'm apparently
watching a bad movie yeah like Attack of
the Clones I don't think is a well made
movie but I just like being there it's
like it's like why even if I could I'm
aware it's bad I think we consistently
praised that world that they inhabit and
how tangible they make it but as time
has gone on the things I have issues
with now I'm like really a 50/50 now as
opposed to 6040 it's like with the last
Jedi I I really actually loved it when I
first saw it and then after binging them
my opinion has drastically dipped my
opinion on the this latest trilogy has
actually dipped significantly cuz once I
got to force awakens I watch this in
timeline order once I got to force
awakens suddenly I was like oh this is
what a Disney Star Wars movie I just
gotta say even with this they're one as
a trilogy it does not flow yeah it's
it's the hodgepodge of your cluster
ideas and then watching this movie I
give a lot of benefit of the doubt to
the fact of how much fun I had in the
immediacy of it that's not enjoyable
theater experience I mean yeah not
everyone's gonna say that for me for us
I had fun watching it but there was a
plenty of things I had major issues and
things I was just rolling my eyes at but
I don't think the Star Wars saga the
Skywalker saga is perfect and it's like
it's not like every film is great and
then this happened you know it's like
the prequels are suddenly praised I
really think Revenge of this is the only
like actual good movie out of there
whatever we're not going to that because
with this movie JJ was setting out to do
a lot of things for some reason I
thought they just focus on wrapping up
the trilogy why should I wrap up all
nine movies after watching this movie
I'm like why did you try to wrap up all
nine movies we didn't need them like we
wrapped up each more of those with those
movies
yes and then of course you know there's
a lot of course correction some stuff
was like whatever to me I'm some stuff
I'm kind of just mutual about and
there's other things where I hated the
way they need a handle the course
correction on things as a film because
some people will say with last Jedi
that's a good Ryan Johnson movie not a
good Star Wars movie so let me just them
really quick as a film not as just a
Star Wars movie I think there's a lot of
messy things about it I pointed out the
dialogue for sure it feels very rushed
and and like a really compact it's like
really convoluted and hit me in the
first hour some parts of me felt like
they were trying to do a proper part two
and a part three at the same time time
and so hence you got this kind of jammed
in two and a half hour film that should
have been like three three and a half
maybe even four the last one in half
like every why a books here yeah or
infinity warning game and I think that
would have been fine yeah especially for
an event like this but anyway there's so
much going on but hey let's kick this
off properly like what the failed or
lackluster a course correction as I like
to put it the Emperor
right from the opening crawl the first
line I dead speak exclamation mark
Emperor Palpatine is back they said they
got this voice transmission and then
kylo Ren being Supreme Leader is hunting
him down because he's threatening anyone
who will take away his power position
when the last Jedi ended some people are
like where does the movie go from here
and then with last year's like well it's
pretty obvious Ray's gonna have to
embody the the Jedi somehow kylo Ren is
supreme leader so I thought it was cool
that they kill I have no wishes of them
killing off Snoke I don't really need to
learn who's no kids there are a lot of
evil overlords that we deal with in
these movies so my thing though was like
I liked how it was service in the way to
make kylo Ren supreme leader to make him
the ultimate baddie for the third one
I'm like what a unique way to build up
the villains yeah and a guy who we've
really spent a lot of time with you know
and this movie completely undercut that
right in the first 10 minutes of the
film the opening crawl when they're
talking about what they will that the
transmission and stuff I'm like man that
would have been a cool scene to actually
see instead of just getting this text
and acting like this is what I was
supposed to always happen with the
Emperor
returning like there's no see it clearly
feels like course-correction
I have a really hard time believing
because Colin Trevorrow even came out
and defended JJ Abrams saying that no he
actually already always had plans for
the Emperor to go there maybe not maybe
yes but it does not flow with the
previous movie there cuz yeah it feels
like a random inclusion of this
character with nothing leading up to it
except for a one-line retcon of I am
every voice kylo shows up finds the
Emperor I still don't know how I feel
about the whole sift finder they call it
a super basic like for all the cool
names if they have like a finder as a
real thing but yeah yeah it seems like a
unobtainium kind of thing where it's
like oh really you couldn't be a little
more creative you know I was gonna get
this out of the way do not explain how
the Emperor's back at all really except
for he's just so evil that he didn't die
I guess I watch Return of the Jedi
recently I'm like no he he dead yeah if
this had been a longer movie or if this
had been in a different form and fleshed
out I think it could have been
interesting you know he's really scary
and stuff and yeah I mean they'd really
suffer from under development of most of
their ideas you know what would the kylo
Ren thing kylo Ren shows up killed and
then like five minutes later when we saw
that trailer that kylo Ren meets the
Emperor I thought like oh no it's
literally gonna be a longer smooth out
seeing them nope it kind of plays like
that yeah it's like cutting in yeah yeah
it's really a fast-paced way to open the
movie and then kylo Ren immediately is
like alright I'll surrender it to you
and and be your number one apprentice
again that to me upset me right away
because automatically kylo Ren went from
this cool arc in the last Jedi to oh now
he's just this is just another Emperor
he's working under it instead of Snoke
now it's Palpatine you know and I've and
the whole thing with the mask I thought
was silly because it really started to
feel like okay everything the fans
complained about not just come wanted to
see but complained about they're trying
to just implement here
Knights of Ren er back who by the way do
nothing again kylo Ren nobody cool and
they're they're alive
so yeah kylo Ren he puts his mask back
together what's the point of the mask
that when snow called him out on the
mask in the last Jedi despite whatever
things you think undercut Star Wars the
Lord and everything in the last Jedi
smoke at a point he's like take that
stupid thing off he isn't like he
doesn't need the mask yeah no it doesn't
it's not like it's helping him breathe
or anything nor does the movie who
properly flesh out why and what is just
one it's not a if he's rocking a Darth
Vader mask as he wants to be Darth Vader
okay but he's not it's not a Darth Vader
mask yes or you know it's kind of a
knockoff of it or it's based inspired
some mini version yeah so it was at the
point when I like as I was watching it
going why didn't you just get a
different mask why did you fight you to
reassemble this one because the cool red
adhesive in there to show how much into
the dark side it doesn't even wear it
for half of the movie I know yeah I mean
I I personally think the design is cool
but I don't understand the purpose of it
at all other than cosmetic and I'm like
why would this be so concerned with
cosmid their mess yeah yeah like the
outward appearance I want to touch a
little bit on the whole rapes parents
and raise a character god mode ability
we learn Rey who raised parents are kind
of oh that was my biggest eye-roll
moment in the movie I don't know what
everyone's biggest eye-roll moment in
the last Jedi she says my parents were
nobody your parents were nobody you know
who says it in this movie it's literally
like in that episode of The Simpsons
where they find the book like how to
cook humans and they blow the dust off
and that says how to cook for Hume you
know nobody's they chose to be oh man so
dad they could have rolled with it in
some way or whatever but that's what
they chose to do and could have earned
it I think I don't I don't entirely hate
the choice because I understand why you
would use that to hurt somebody the
movie doesn't earn it I
just would have been better if kylo was
like yeah I lied yeah yeah yeah don't
even the dialogue was bad Rey being a
descendant of Palpatine opens up a lot
of questions I don't think that was the
original plan it doesn't read that way
it doesn't feel that way admittedly
though the scene when Chewie they think
Chewie ship yeah and then kylo shows up
and they're having a stand because
honestly when raised started like
because there's already a couple things
that happen in the movie that just made
me roll my eyes which was raised life
force ability which I know is in Star
Wars thing but but the problem is is how
does Rey do it just because she is
Palpatine's descendant she's Palpatine's
granddaughter and that she had very
minor training from Luke and mainly
trained from Leia apparently which is a
nugget I kind of like actually I like
that
Leia apparently had some training and
they explained when she stopped and the
information I think is cool there are a
lot of interesting ideas potentially
right but her life force abilities her
insane strength still she has to earn it
she has to still develop it and I don't
think this movie solves that at all and
her being Palpatine's granddaughter does
not solve that so when she was holding
the ship back I was like oh my god here
we go she's just unbelievably powerful
then when the light and Sith Lightning
came out of her I went oh that's cool
yeah that I thought that was neat like
who wouldn't interesting intrigue I feel
like some people immediately go oh she
must be Palpatine's granddaughter or
something I feel like some people will
probably go that route um but for in the
moment I thought it was pretty
surprising as I know [ __ ] that must be
the whole evil Club maybe she will go
evil or something you know it started
making me wonder some stuff we don't
really get to know Rey's parents we
don't they're just information pieces
literally I started getting pulled out
of the movie going wait a minute who -
Palpatine sleep with that when did he
when did he maybe maybe some of those
Senate hearings you know they get long
and you know you're with all these
people you don't normally see is this
the new spin-off we're gonna get dark
romance it'll be like Casino Royale
we'll learn how he got his heart broken
and became the Emperor so with it why
why is the granddaughter Palpatine ooh
Dean's granddaughter the one who has
these insane abilities what about did
they say they say the son was it was it
his son that was the immediate one yeah
I think so yeah okay either way
whichever parent it was how come they
don't have the abilities why aren't they
in fact maybe it skips a generation like
certainty yes one of those things were I
have no idea you can muse about it all
day long and maybe come up with a cool
explanation but yeah they rush past it
in the movie and when that came up I
thought the Lightning was cool as well
and again if they had earned it and
spent time with it I thought maybe they
could have worked the Palpatine
connection into something that explains
the immense power raise seems to possess
you see once they said that I started
having theories and the whole like we're
gonna circle back around to everything
in between because I'm about to touch on
the final moment in the movie when she
takes on the Skywalker name I don't
think people are responding to that
really well I don't feel like it's quite
earned don't even quite sure quite did
it if you guys have like reasoning or
theories behind it please leave it below
III honestly watch it and instead of
feeling like the oh it's like you know
she's gonna say Rey Skywalker right you
know you know it but for some reason I'm
like why is she going by Skywalker like
she's just giving herself her own
identity they don't seem like family
figures enough to her in these movies we
haven't maybe like Bond enough may yeah
maybe Leia but I don't really not Luke
especially for the journey that she's on
you know and and there's so much about
her being alone and nobody can connect
to me and nobody's everyone says they
know me and nobody does I would have
found it a bit more powerful had they
just had her either choose her own name
or stay with it's just right yeah
exactly I would have been cool with it
she could be distinct she could be her
own thing exactly so what I thought they
might have been going for though in
terms of trying to wrap up every movie
for some reason oh yeah I get it
we keep talking about his remember I had
a theory I said this in one of our
reactions that I think what they're
trying to do with her is balance both
because they're always talking about
balance in the force
light and dark great Jedi so maybe yeah
that's my point is that because she is
Palpatine's it's just the blood of
Palpatine but chooses the skywalker name
yeah she has found created the balance
in the force or of the Jedi or something
yeah like that's what I thought they
were going for I justified it yeah I
don't think it's clear in the movie no
no like that's what I assumed they were
going for that's just because once I
found out she was a Palpatine I was like
oh she's gonna kill Palpatine she's
gonna choose to be good maybe that's
what they're going for you know so my
mind went there the movie doesn't make
it clear though not especially no like
she has a good amount of emotional stuff
to deal with in this movie so like in
that way Jedi had to sit there all about
the different emotions and how you
handle them kylo is clearly a very
angsty character too so yeah I thought
they would have made that a bit more
powerful in a way cuz I like the themes
that I feel like throughout this new
series the big theme has been people
choosing to go away from their origin or
ever you know Finn defects he was a
stormtrooper and now he's with the
resistance Luke even though everybody
hates it you know life decided to give
up the Jedi life you know like
everybody's going away from their
origins and choosing their own destiny
and yeah I thought even the idea that
her and kylo would be sitting together
could have worked a bit better to make
some kind of balance of some kind it
wasn't ever clear and it ultimately felt
like we just got to defeat the bad guy
yeah in person
kylo to kill her I don't know if his
plan was to make her you know like have
her step in for his place that didn't
make sense to me was it one of the
things it's because one of my main
issues with this movie is every super
easy barely an inconvenience moment it's
chalked up to a feeling the force
everything I don't feel like they
properly grasp how the force I mean I I
don't have a rulebook on it but I know
not everything is chalked up to the
force you know yeah seriously this movie
especially is every little resolve is
like know the force you know things that
I again I think in a way that could have
turned like you know the sport the force
is a relatively spiritual concept there
her writings on the nature of that and
so I thought they could have utilized
that to bring our heroes together in
some way that's true and interesting but
they don't it's just an easy explanation
yeah for every time Finn's like no no
it's over there I don't have any reason
to believe that it's other than this
feeling you know let's talk about kylo
changing
and a little bit of Leia within there
because she's important to that and I
did say that's why I really like what
they did with her here I feel like some
people don't really like that what how
they Hammond her but we're all aware of
the situation that occurred and they had
to work around and I think with what
they worked around it was really
effective and then of course reloj yay
when they kissed half the crowd hated
having the crowd was a plot it was so
weird because it was so scattered well
yeah because it is both it's like it's
something it personally I don't I don't
like it in this movie at all I mean like
I could see a version where ray and kylo
come together and that could be cool but
no like the kiss comes out of nowhere
like there's no romance or tenderness
between them at all other than you know
they just saved each other in ways so
yeah I mean it's it's pretty cheesy this
is the kiss and the whole thing with
them creates this like hodgepodge allure
just who their characters are them even
having a romance someone brought up to
me saying does it kind of feel like to
sit one then if Rey is the winner it
creates this whole little weird thing
honestly I feel like you could just end
a Return of the Jedi and kind of just
take how whatever you want these to be
have to be Canon in your eyes had to do
this and I mean ultimately it does feel
like the same they got a bigger weapon
and a bigger more evil space Lord and we
got to go vanquish them and learn a few
things about destiny versus choice but
back to kylo kylo doesn't do like jack
for half the movie I just I don't like
how in this trilogy he just kept losing
array I think every time he lost the
right pretty much and then in this one
when he's in the mass they don't give
him much to do because that's what was
so disappointing with kylo was that
especially in the first half of this
movie him in the mask is not really a
character honestly the forced vision
stuff and our whenever they were able to
talk to each other that was established
in the last Jedi I thought was a little
bit more ambiguous there's a moment
whatever the necklace is there or yeah
the beads they should be hearing from
the celebration kylo picks it up cuz cuz
Luke handed it to Leia in the last Jedi
and then it fades in his hands Kyla
fades in Kyla's hands in the last Jedi
so I was like okay so it wasn't really
there but in this movie apparently could
like hand off
lightsabers [ __ ] which was so cool in
the moment I thought it was cool like ah
neat but then it made me go wait how
does this worry exactly well yeah and
again it's like if we had been
witnessing them both getting stronger
and developing more and more force power
it could have read better cuz I liked a
lot of those sequences yet in the moment
but one thing they actually made me
start to wonder is if he's communicating
with her this way and he's powerful with
the force and Palpatine obviously is
powerful with the force why is he
telling her like I'm gonna betray this
guy in mind-links it seems like the
worst place to do it like because it
seems like Palpatine could probably tap
into that information any time and how
did kylo know that she was the
granddaughter of Palpatine I don't know
whatever it doesn't matter
back to kylo and his change all right
the whole Princess Leia resolved that
they did here I thought was awesome in
the sense of how her death was a
motivation using her life force cuz life
force is all over this movie and using
the last of her life force in order to
have a connection that ultimately serves
as a great distraction for Rey in the
moment need to have a connection with
kylo to help bring him back to his
humanity and then also I did appreciate
the life force nugget she has it because
I thought okay they're gonna kill kylo
off here when he's distracted and she
takes his lightsaber and stabs him his
lightsaber hers I forget anyway stabs
him and then heals him bringing kylo
back to a human grounded moment with
Leia's death and what the purpose they
the way they served it and how they used
it to motivate the story forward I
actually appreciate it I thought it was
handled pretty well and honestly I
couldn't tell whether one it was like
weird green screen or whatever the hell
they had to do I wasn't distracted by
anything with Leia at to me it fit
except for the perfunctory de-aging
flashback why do they feel like every
movement has to have a DEA agent you
don't need that you can just kept the
mask you didn't even need to have the oh
gosh han Solo shows up there's something
like a random appearances in here that
are not so surprising but they happen so
Han Solo shows up and I don't like that
as a general movie trope BVS did it when
with Clark talking to his father getting
advice from a ghost who's not a real
ghost ghost dad yeah Nitori ghost dad
and when he first showed up it wasn't a
surprise necessarily they explained
you're just a memory and I get what they
were going for it felt like in their
scripting and outline they were like
we redo the lines from the force awakens
and but but instead of him stabbing him
he throws it oh oh full circle but it
just played it's kind of corny to me
again but it works yeah nicely tied
motif but yeah it feels like a random
thing I get it especially coming off the
last Jedi more and more and more because
it does seem like they tried to make a
part three two part one
yeah well the Easter eggs in the Nuggets
and everything planted for Kyla to
eventually go to the light side have
been established and so the force
awakens and all fairness that seems to
be the constant struggle and the battle
that they keep having with Kyla like
there's lighting you seriously there's
lighting you I can feel it we all can
feels like in return the Jedi with Vader
it's the Luke fights her that in Return
of the Jedi but not the other ones and
in this one it's been throughout all the
films but there's something about the
way how it's handled in this movie that
felt odd like when he's running to save
to help out Rey and he's kind of
embodying a little bit more of a han
Solo kind of idea you know what I mean
yeah when he's just in the blaster pants
yeah there's something that seemed a
little bit off to me about it I don't
know exactly what it was because when
they have that showdown there was a lot
of confusing elements in that showdown
with with Emperor Palpatine when they
sucked the life force out of them yeah
what was that that was one of the few
things that in the moment I I was like
that's [ __ ]
I mean they're shipping the life force
out of them and then Rey uses ultimate
force on him a few minutes later I was
like what was the whole point of sucking
the life force out of them exactly and
how did you not do that she's like what
do you do then and how did Kai how was
kylo able to transfer life force to Rey
when she was dead if the life force was
sucked out of here you know all these
things were just kind of confusing and
super easy barely an inconvenience
justification is the life force work is
it like a jug where like if you're poor
I know you know right we both split it
then we're both kind of waning away like
again this movie really suffers at the
hands of its pace and I think it's easy
to enjoy in the minute because there are
a lot of interesting ideas and you're
going along for the adventure and
there's all the lights and sounds and
actors who are doing a good job but yeah
everything starts to raise question
and holes when you look back on them
because they don't have enough time to
drive the emotions home to motivate
these things there are things in here
like Easter Egg stuff that I really
think they work a little bit bogged down
by trying to tie in all nine movies
there's a thing in the concept of her
when she met he was like meditating
trying to connect with the with all the
Fallen Jedi the past Jedi that I liked
and honestly like when when she's like
using the last of her abilities to
conjure up some energy and she's hearing
all the voices of actors from the past
samjha hear their voices Sam Jackson /
Hayden Christensen oh oh there's Liam
Neeson hey you know like I'm hearing all
their voices and greatest hits of the
Jedi and this and because I binge the
movies I think the in my instant
reaction to really having a fun time
with this really did work on my
nostalgia with with the film because I
had so much fresh in my mind
I've wonder how P Ford is gonna react to
the whole thing of all the Jedi live in
me now do they I don't yeah I really
wish they just killed her off more
powerful yeah yeah yeah just died for
the cause or something or you know
sacrifice herself for the ultimate
victory you know me oh yeah yeah and
when did I told you that there was like
weird Matrix Revolutions vibes yeah yeah
where they're trying to resolve a lot
and a lot of things and but at the same
time it's like it feels like it's going
for a dark feel but it kind of feels
like cheesy instead of like really dark
yeah it's not empire or anything no and
where she ends up I just don't have
usually there's a sense of finality or a
sense that like oh yeah she'll go on to
other adventures and where it ended I
was like I don't know what her what her
drive she's gonna turn into after this
they raise a lot of confusing things and
there are things that are here that are
just wasted or completely dropped they
have a whole thing established that I
thought they were gonna finally wrap up
because Finn is clearly into ray yeah in
the force awakens yes and he spends a
lot of the last Jedi just gets ready get
ready if I'm ready you know they had the
moment where and they're in the and the
sinking sand need to tell you something
right and I never told you
and it's this joke that keeps being
brought up and you're like okay I get it
we're gonna get to a point where Finn
finally confesses his feelings for her
so when reloj kiss happened what
I just don't think was earned and it's
just awkward what is that like upset me
like I actually got like irritated with
that like I wasn't having a bad time at
that moment but that was also one where
I was like really feel so it is no pun
intended it's forced at funk tree and
playing into a meme or some [ __ ] I don't
know it says oh man it's gonna be
awkward for Finn when he finally the
nope he does not tell her he doesn't he
doesn't tell her they'd never tie that
thread Finn doesn't have a carrot his
arc was really wrapped in force awakens
and they do nothing with him here
Knights of Ren were still nothing
general Hux being a spy was a funny
moment admittedly
when it happened I like that at the time
it was funny his reasoning and then him
getting killed off a second later and
then I actually was sitting back going
wait spy what did he help out with
exactly giving them information like
trickling them information on the
down-low
what was that you know I'm not sure I'd
have to go back and I don't remember
whether or not they'd specify in the
movie but you know maybe it's in there
there's a lot of information being
thrown our way the whole time oh I
remember it's when they docked the
Millennium Falcon and they down at the
beginning r2 and he says we've got a spy
in oh yes yes oh but yeah but what was
he in for my days matter but the general
Hux motivation I thought was silly the
way the Huck's character was treated
this whole trilogy is like a [ __ ] he's
such a pitch sniveling and yeah it was
funny the reveal but at the same time
just they didn't do anything with it you
come off right you know what I you know
what I don't like about that I liked
everything up until he said I don't care
if you win I just care if they lose what
motivation is that like why would you
put yourself at that much risk and rise
to this level in an organization if you
don't care about anything Rose sidelines
like a mofo oh yeah she's in a few shots
like she wasn't the Jar Jar Binks of
this franchise what the hell's going on
why she like what to decide so the Luke
Skywalker surprise not really a surprise
man what a course correction dialogue
interaction that whoa
this thing deserves a Jedi's weapon
deserves more respect than man yes I was
wrong I was wrong Oh remember every I
don't know what I said that last movie
but but just clear it from your mind and
I couldn't tell if they thought they
were wrapping something up or if it was
just an easter egg when he lifts the
x-wing out of the water
obviously referencing to the Empire
Strikes Back when he couldn't lift it
out of the water in Yoda did it for him
but man everything is just such a
comedian Avery doesn't advocate like
abilities I'm sorry like she doesn't
even lift it out it's a it's a it's a
it's a Jedi ghost who does it for but
there are sequences that I do the others
know after all this there are additional
sequences I did enjoy I did like the the
first chase sequence in the Millennium
Falcon Falcon space jump yeah the
hyperspace jeomsun kinda matter made a
Thor the dark world yeah they're jumping
between realms but I thought it was like
cooler here just to see that this for
what we knew about what the ship can
handle tension the zouri bliss character
I thought was she was all right I like
that like what you did with Poe
especially loved would Poe look at her
at the end like see that's you know like
that was very cute and I loved that Keri
Russell decided just to stay in the mat
like what right like partway through the
movie I was like wait a minute is that
Keri Russell because she's the only
person whose face I haven't seen I
recognize her eyes or ladies what a
visor moment here I reckon I was able to
tell that was her when that popped up
then you droid I thought was funny kind
of yo yeah remember that guy on a wheel
yeah who's cool yeah funny he was
traumatized it just didn't want to be
treated poorly anymore the music was
great that goes without saying one of
the best songs is in the still my the
one I
despite the only one I truly do not
enjoy watching is the Phantom Menace the
Phantom Menace has one of the best Star
Wars songs ever one of my favorite songs
ever do all the fates I just love that
you know so yeah the music in here is
awesome great special effects yeah
puppetry and dressing and costume a new
character who by the Death Star thing
couldn't tell volando had a we were they
setting up a new movie with them is that
what they were doing
Oh Lana is like where are you from I
don't know let's go find out I couldn't
tell if he was hitting on her or saw her
as like he could be a father that was an
odd yeah I don't know what that was
supposed to be I think that's just a
line he used to get her in a ship well
anyway guys look I know this was long a
lot to talk about
thank you for being here what did you
think of the rise of Skywalker what are
you hoping for they do with the future
of the Star Wars franchise Mandalorian
still killing it at least this one
doesn't seem as divisive I guess not
I mean if there was a 50/50 split on who
likes and who doesn't but I think the
main split that happened with last Jedi
was the critics loved it
the fans hated it and it just seems like
no I think everyone's gonna be split I
think it's where the war happened
between like here it I feel like it's
gonna be pretty much 50/50 but you just
feel it in the crowd yeah half the fans
were loving it
half the fans were not liking it I
bumped into people who gave quick
opinion who were like really not for
this and people who really were for it I
can have fun and watch this I can and I
and I did have fun and watch it I don't
know where I ultimately fall my opinions
for these movies tend to switch and of
all the changes grow over time once you
put it on camera it's finite you cannot
change your mind you cannot or else
you're a hypocrite and a liar who don't
think about it any more than this do not
develop or nuance your feelings how can
I trust you if you change your opinion
ever further examination you say never
never maybe I'll change on second
viewing alright guys well thanks for
being here subscribe to the real rejects
click the notification bell thank you to
hosting juror for sponsoring this video
and go to the special link get 91
percent off see you guys